Donald trump,
president of the United States and the
world's most powerful man.
A lot has been said about his auntie
liberal agenda,
but the question today is can he really
put it all into place?
The bigger question here,
the how powerful is the presidents of
the United States?
Really?
Let's have a look at it
as an example,
Donald Trump would get up one morning
and launched a couple of nuclear
warheads to another country without
passing.
A congress can listen,
is all the supreme court stop the
massive deportations that he's proposed
during his campaign.
Don't forget,
it's a democracy in the United States,
congratulates itself Fur.
It's clear distinction between executive
judicial and legislative branches.
This system of checks and balances once
designed to prevent an eventual
psychopath from taking over the country
and it's creating chaos like seizing the
power that he was given,
buying the citizen with this system in
place.
The presidents of the United States or
Otis has a lot of authority to do things
unilaterally without having to ask
permission of any court parliaments and
believe you me,
some of these things are pretty darn
scary today.
In this video,
we're going to tell you about some of
the things that Donald Trump can do by
himself and we're doing it along with
our friend Eric [inaudible].
Eric is the cofounder of reconsider
media,
one of the most influential political
podcasts in America.
Hello Simon and hello to all the visual
politics subscribers.
That's the nuclear football exists.
The answer is,
Oh yes,
it does,
because when you play Football,
Aka the Doomsday Boston does exist.
In fact,
it's carried in the briefcase that we're
showing in the picture.
Yeah.
President presses that button.
He's sending an order to to US army
officials.
Usually lieutenants were stationed
aboard a combat jet that has a nuclear
weapon.
Each of these lieutenants has a key.
When they turned those keys,
at the same time they deploy and launch
the nuclear weapon.
Be Wondering,
is it required that Congress passed a
law or some kind of special order in
order to launch that nuke,
and the answer is a resounding no.
The presidents can give the order to
launch and you just about any time he
wants.
Just like
resident could push the button all by
himself or herself legally and
constitutionally speaking,
physically,
military personnel would need to carry
out the strike.
Of course,
any military officer ignoring a
presidential order would be an opening
subordination subject to dismissal and
court martialed.
All of this comes from the time of the
Cold War.
The United States felt existentially
threatened by the Soviet Union.
They worried that eventually the Soviets
would be able to nuke any American city
at any time.
If this would be the case,
the United States.
We need to be able to react with the
retaliatory strike immediately.
There wouldn't be time for debate in the
House of Representatives.
Hold on a minute here because there is
much more.
Imagine Donald Trump wakes up one
morning and Zinzi isn't a big fan of the
Chinese people.
He decides to launch a new gas in
Beijing.
From a legal and constitutional point of
view,
he is allowed to do so,
but this isn't going to be for free.
In this example,
launching a bombing against China would
violate several international treaties
as well as agreements between the United
States and China.
This means the US Congress would ask him
for an explanation or even call for a
vote to decide whether he should be
kicked out of the Oval Office or not.
This is a process called impeachment and
it comes into effect when the
president's breaks a law,
including treaties that the US has
agreed to.
Former presidents like Richard Nixon are
rather familiar with this process.
This is not the ends of things though
because there is far more than nukes in
America's arsenal and a state of
emergency,
so can Donald Trump declare war on
another country all by himself?
However,
in cases of emergency,
the president can actually send troops
into another country without a
declaration of war by Congress ahead of
time.
Here's thing
example,
President Obama is facing criticism that
crosses the political divide for not
seeking congressional authorization
before ordering the American military to
join in attacks,
tax of Libyan earth defenses and
government forces.
This means that if trump wanted to send
troops to a country like Iran,
for example,
you can absolutely do it,
but you can only do it for 60 days.
After that 60 day period,
he has to report to Congress and gets a
vote declaring war.
This would mean an extended military
presence in the territory,
so this means that you can send troops
to a country if it's an emergency,
but you can't send them there if you
want them to stay for longer.
In that case,
you do need Congress to approve this.
Nonetheless,
once Congress has declared a declaration
of war,
the president has the power to
micromanage the war,
however they want.
Nonetheless,
once Congress has passed a declaration
of war,
the president as commander in chief has
the power to micromanage the war,
however they can.
Nonetheless.
Last one is congress has passed a
declaration of war.
The president is unable to micromanage
the warfare,
the as much as he wants.
This means the president can give very
specific and detailed orders.
If you remember the capture of Osama bin
Laden that was directed by President
Obama in self,
and then there they're also the many
drone strikes.
The President Obama also watered
himself.
Let's now move on from warfare and let's
talk a little bit about economics.
Well,
to the free trade agreements,
when it comes to the economy,
almost all domestic policies do you have
to go through congress.
If Donald trump wants to raise taxes,
it would require a legislative votes.
The same happens if he wants to
liberalize one industry or nationalized
another.
In many cases,
he might face the Supreme Court or even
individual states who have their own
power to stop some actions and that's
something we're actually going to be
covering in an upcoming video.
Nonetheless,
that is an area where Donald Trump will
have power to act.
However you want international trade
agreements,
and this is really no small matter,
US companies buy and sell goods and
services all over the world,
and these commercial relationships are
regulated through international
agreements.
Yes,
many governments have special taxes
which are called tariffs on foreign
goods.
In order to avoid these countries can
sign what they call a free trade
agreement.
You're in North America,
we have the Nafta Treaty or the North
American Free Trade Association,
which allows for forms of free trade
between the United States,
Canada,
and Mexico.
Now this law is 20 years old and because
it's already on the books,
Donald Trump cannot unilaterally break
it or change it in any major way.
You would need congress to pass a new
law in order to make change.
Nevertheless,
they're all two other big treaties that
were negotiated by Barack Obama that are
still to be passed through congress.
The first is the TPP.
This allows a form of free trade between
America and Asia and Oceania.
The other risk of the TT ip which opens
commerce with the European Union.
These treaties were almost done.
They just needed to be passed by the
American Congress as well as the
legislative bodies of some other
countries.
However,
the American constitution says that any
president can renegotiate or cancel any
international treaties before they have
been voted on by Congress,
and even if they were approved by the
legislature,
you could still choose not to sign it if
he didn't sign it.
This would be called a veto,
and as you probably well know,
trump is no big fan of free trade and
the TPP failed.
GPP is a horrible deal.
It is a deal that is going to lead to
nothing but trouble.
It's a deal that was designed for China
to come in as they always do through the
backdoor and truck.
Totally take advantage of everyone.
In fact,
the president can veto any law passed by
Congress,
however,
he can only veto the whole law or and
send it back to Congress.
He cannot pick and choose what parts of
the Walgett past once it's sent back to
Congress.
If Congress wants to pass it over the
veto,
they would have to vote for it with a
two thirds majority,
but of course,
the main area where Donald Trump would
like to use this super as presidents is
great.
This was the most hated,
yes,
most repeated word in donald trump's
speeches during his entire election
campaign.
Nonetheless,
he almost has no executive powers with
which and can act on this matter
in order to build the wall.
Trump actually needs congressional
approval because at the end of the day,
it's a major civil construction
projects,
so it needs a budget which congress
passes and it also needs big land
allocations,
which he needs Congress to acquire as
well.
If he's going to build the wall without
the permission of any other American
institution,
he actually has to get not only Mexico
to pay for the wall,
but also to build the wall with in their
own border.
This is again something that we're going
to be talking about lazy
now,
the American system only that's trump.
Do one thing or to the Department of
Homeland Security to prioritize the
deportation of illegal immigrants,
but you know what's particularly
interesting about this and what the
problem is,
and that's the Boma.
Well,
he already did that.
Doesn't had Obama Administration so
strange as it sounds when it comes to
illegal immigration.
Trump's administration is expected to
follow the steps of it promise.
This is our opinion here.
Revisional,
politic,
and now we'd love to know what you
think.
Do you think that the president should
be able to meet so many unilateral
decisions without having to go through
Congress?
You think it's kind of scary that one
person has the authority,
didn't nuke whatever country you'd
wants?
Well,
you can let us know what you think by
leaving us a comment below.
We do love reading them and love to know
what you guys think and do not forget
that we put out brand new videos every
Monday and Thursday,
so do be sure to subscribe.
There is a button below me as well as on
the screen now and don't forget to give
this video a thumbs up if you did enjoy
it and I'll be back next time with
another brand new video.
The.